[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my
non-spoilery review of stranger things
season 2 I'll talk about some of the
stuff that I felt like worked really
well over season one it was basically
them taking all the good stuff from
season one and turning the knob up to 11
so they spent way more on special
effects they did a much better job of
plotting their story out but if you
didn't know I'm doing a movie ticket
giveaway right now just because there's
so many movies coming out it can be for
anything you want all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this but like I
said overall takeaway is that this was a
much better version of season 1 they
broaden the mythology in an interesting
way the duffer brothers said that they
have a four to five season plan so
that's all that they're expecting this
series to run so I will be doing Easter
egg videos after this and I'll explain a
little bit more specifically about what
they tease with that big ending but
overall I feel like there were only a
few things that didn't work for me there
were a few characters that I don't think
worked out really well there were a few
story choices in between some of the
other mythology episodes that I don't
think work quite as well but I think
some of the weirder stuff that they
tease they'll just follow up on on
season 3 so we'll talk about that very
specific episode that everybody's really
confused by because they do this really
cool thing where Empire Strikes Back
remember we're talking about the 80s
Empire Strikes Back splits the groups
apart and then they each have their own
storylines this sort of intersect and
then eventually come back around to meet
each other by the end of the story so
without doing spoilers 11 just had some
very specific separate storylines off by
herself that they probably won't get to
till season 3 but I think the only
reason why people were a little
dissatisfied with the placement of that
particular episode was is because it
felt so different from what was going on
and so disconnected so just remember
they're planting a lot of seeds for
season 3 season 4 season 5 but probably
the best performances were the kids and
you can kind of tell how they double
down on the kids during season 2 now in
season 1 you have the adult storyline
you have the teenagers and then you have
the kids the things that they changed
about this season is that they sort of
mix the groups up so you get a lot of
the teenagers with
kids and I feel like they did a much
better job balancing some of the adults
storylines so Hopper always has some of
the best performances Winona Ryder's
character was a little more well
balanced she had to play crazy for
pretty much all of season one they bring
her down just a little bit for season
two so I feel like she was great and I
know a lot of people are always hyping
up Finn wolfhard because he was in the
it movie and there's a lot of it movie
inside stranger things they take a lot
of Stephen King inspiration the funny
thing that's actually been happening
since the new it movie came out and blew
up is that a lot of younger people that
have gone to see it have actually
thought that it's ripping off stranger
things so I'm sure that they promptly
got slapped in the street just because
so much of stranger things is built on
the bones of Steven Spielberg Stephen
King in a whole bunch of 80s pop culture
the only real character that didn't work
for me at all was Billy Hargrove so if
you don't know who he is he was actually
in the Power Rangers movie but they
brought him on to season two to
specifically be a villain so if you
thought he was a big that's
because he was written to be an
for all the characters like you have the
supernatural threats then you have the
human threats they wanted Billy to be
that human threat for the younger
characters so he did that really well
but he was just so over the top and so
on the nose and I just couldn't stand
that 80's haircut I know this is
supposed to be set in the 80s but it's
almost like the character was a badly
written version of a Karate Kid Cobra
Kai villain so that sort of gets to my
other point like one of the few things
that I felt like just didn't work for
this series is the way they were so on
the nose with some of their references
like all the music that they used was
great but the way that they used it
tended to be very on the nose like oh
they're all wearing their Ghostbusters
costumes so we're gonna play the
Ghostbusters song sometimes the music
that they use didn't always do the best
job of commenting on the action like if
you're noticing the music then it's
taking you out of the story and it's not
doing its job the way it should so it
was a great playlist overall but I feel
like they went back to that well too
often in the music that they actually
composed for the series the weird synth
music that's actually really good
so they actually should have relied on
that a little bit more Millie Bobby
Brown feels like she's matured a lot
since season 1 her performance reflected
that some of her dialogue
was a little on the nose like when she
was taking her principled stands friends
don't lie like I feel like at this point
she would probably learn to speak a
little bit better so hopefully by the
time we get to season 3 she's actually
speaking complete sentences or she's
just beaming her thoughts to the other
children that would actually be
acceptable and they actually do some
cool things in broadening the mythology
of how her powers work like I was saying
there's a particular episode that felt
really weird during this season it sort
of sets up the larger mythology of the
other children at the Hawkins laboratory
like she's number 11 that means that
there are at least 10 other kids and
we'll probably learn more about them
when we get to season 3 so that was sort
of a left turn for the season but it
could turn into something interesting in
a future season who knows moving towards
the series ending and sort of the set
ups for season 2 without getting into
super spoilers I feel like they did a
good job of wrapping up the challenge of
season 2 while at the same time letting
you know that this is not over
like they get a pretty definitive ending
but throughout the season they do a good
job of reminding you why they got into
this situation how it got started and
then based on some of the new characters
they introduced like collied number
eight you get some ideas about how that
threat might come back but they did do a
good job of wrapping the logic up with
the characters so you understand why 11
can walk around in broad daylight where
she can't during the beginning of the
season while she's being hunted down and
why that's different by the end it is
overall I think they did a good job of
exploring the characters in a way that
they didn't during season one they said
one of their big goals was to do
separate little storylines they didn't
have time for in season 1 and that's
really where you get to that separate 11
storyline you learn about hoppers
backstory you learn more about his
family you learn more about hoppers
relationship back in school with wills
mom like they actually had something
between them so just provide some
context for shifting relationships and
character dynamics in season 3 in
addition to all the big mythology stuff
that they teased so I don't think I've
mentioned it but probably one of the
best things that I like about stranger
things over some of the other Netflix
series like Marvel's and Netflix series
is the fact that it's only eight to nine
episodes season two just had that one
extra episode but the Marvel Netflix
shows have been doing this thing
they do 13 episodes but they only have
about six episodes of story
so that was one of the big complaints
about stranger things season 1 is it
took a long time to get where it was
going
season 2 gets there a lot faster but
they had some great new characters
hopper is probably still my favorite I
mean 11 is really cool but out of all
the new people I probably like Mad Max
the best and Paul Reiser was just funny
just seeing him in all those old 80's
and 90's television shows that I used to
watch and then seeing him in this was
just kind of funny but let me know in
the comments what did you think about
season 2 who's your favorite character
and what do you want them to follow up
on in season 3 congratulations to Darius
Howard you're the latest giveaway winner
I have some more flash and Marvel stuff
to post this weekend so I'll try to get
that out as fast as possible you can
click here for my non-spoilery Thor
Ragnarok review and you can click here
for the last real big Justice League
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight